measles is one of the most contagious
diseases we know just one person is
likely to infect between 12 and 18
people that number is called a diseases
basic reproduction number or are not
scientists use it to describe how
contagious diseases Zika it has an R
nought of up to six point six super
contagious but the seasonal flu just a
little over one and kovat nineteen the
disease caused by the corona virus just
about to that difference between the flu
and covin eighteen doesn't seem so big
especially when you look at them next to
these really contagious diseases plus a
lot of the symptoms of the flu and Kovan
19 are really similar a fever cough they
can even both lead to pneumonia which is
ultimately how they can both be fatal so
thinking of Cova 19 and the flu is
similar is a common and frankly
understandable comparison to want to
make this is like the flu it's a lot
like the flu I like to believe that it's
going to end up more like the flu virus
but wait let's go back to those are not
numbers again if the flu has an R nought
of 1.3 that means each person gets
either one or two people sick after 10
rounds that's 56 total people and if we
run the model with Kovan nineteen's are
not at - if one person with it gets two
people sick you get two people sick
after 10 rounds that's more than 2,000
people this does not happen with the flu
because Kovan 19 is very different and
understanding how is crucial to
understanding how dangerous it really is
and why we have to take it so seriously
[Music]
when we start to like look for that
comparison to the flu
we almost like calm ourselves down but
unfortunately that's not quite the right
reaction here every year the seasonal
flu kills as many as 60,000 Americans as
of late March kufan 19 is killed about
34,000 across the whole world but
scientists expect that number to go up
way up tens of thousands of people a
year die of the flu but we haven't had
this for a year yet we found only have
this for a few months
the trouble is coming and we can predict
it and we can see what's coming at least
to certain extent
the first really big difference between
Kovan 19 and the flu is how long it
takes you to feel sick from the moment
you're infected with Cova 19 it usually
takes five days before you start to feel
symptoms but it can take as long as 12
or even 14 days this is the incubation
period the time between when you catch
it and when you first realize you're
sick and scientists think you could be
contagious during most of this period
the flu by comparison has an average
incubation period of just two days you
get sick and pretty soon you feel sick
and you know you're contagious this is
what we're used to but kovat nineteen
flips that around you can be contagious
and spreading it around for several days
and up to two weeks before it even
occurs to you that you're sick and that
leads to the next big difference no
human immune system had seen this virus
before nobody has a natural immunity to
it in flu season there's always a number
of people in the population who are
already immune to the flu that can be
because they got their flu shot or maybe
they've already had that flu strain and
that limits the spread of the virus when
one person is contagious with the flu
they can only spread it to people who
aren't immune who can only spread it to
other people who aren't immune that's
why scientists and doctors urge us to
get our flu shot every year if enough
people have immunity they can kind of
shield the virus from reaching others
the more immunized people the more they
can protect those that are susceptible
to the virus but covet 19 is brand
none of us have had it before and
there's no vaccine which means nearly
everyone on the planet is susceptible so
when a contagious person who may not
even know they're infected
comes into contact with others it can
spread like wildfire and then you see
how much more dangerous Cova 19 can be
only two percent of people with the flu
need to be hospitalized but 22 even 30%
of people's who test positive for kuva
19 do and we're still learning about
covin 19's fatality rate but scientists
think it's somewhere between 1 and 3
percent but the flus rate is even lower
0.1% and that's a disease that can kill
60,000 people a year in the US alone
that's what dr. Anthony Fauci the u.s.
is leading infectious disease expert
tried to clear up to Congress people
always say well the flu you know the flu
does this the flu does that the flu has
a mortality of 0.1% this has a mortality
of 10 times that this is a really
serious problem that we have to take
seriously and he's just talking about
the average across all age groups for
older people or people with compromised
immune systems it can be way higher and
that's especially scary when you
remember all the other things that are
different about kovin 19 the
infectiousness how hard it is to know
you have it how susceptible we all are
to it estimates vary but some scientists
have warned that between 20 and 60
percent of the world's population could
become infected with the virus
because kovat 19 has no cure and no
vaccine the only defense we have against
it is social we can take ourselves out
of the chain not with immunity but with
social distancing just physically not
being around anyone and stayin home as
much as possible but that only works if
each of us takes it seriously which is
why comparing it to the flu while
understandable is not helpful it's
natural to want to find a comparison to
want to make the seem small when we use
the flu as the backdrop it almost numbs
us for a cat anomalous and make us maybe
even feel better about the current
situation
the current situation is bad so now is
not the time to be Nam we need to be
vigilant and use our vigilance for
useful actions
[Music]